pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
colombes une nouvelle fois à l'heure de
la coupe de france de football à
l'occasion des quarts de finale qui
oppose nice maillot france et à monaco
au maillot père par conséquent ni ses
favoris et c'est sans doute pour cela
qu'il conduit les premières attaques
[Musique]
et à ce petit jeu le noir baroux numéro
11 pourtant piètre technicien s'en
donnent à coeur joie
le voici encore il va s'y reprendre à
deux fois pour marquer son but une fois
deux fois but
[Applaudissements]
voilà qui commence mal pour monaco qui
cependant reprend la direction du jeu
certes l'immense barre ou fait encore
des siennes mais il est vraiment trop
isolés pour battre une nouvelle fois le
gardien de but monégasque c'est
maintenant l'heure de monaco et voilà un
premier but il n'a pas tardé à être
suivi d'un second but qui va marquer
cossou cossou qui comme fontaine
semblait perdu pour le football à la
suite d'une fracture de la jambe et qui
maintenant je joue beaucoup mieux
qu'avant sa blessure l'avait dit sentir
un petit chef-d'oeuvre
voilà qui est encourageant confrontés et
c'est ainsi que monaco se qualifie pour
les demi finales de la coupe de france
en battant nice par 3 un spécialiste du
ballet du torchon ces honorables sujets
de sa majesté britannique ne manque pas
de qualités sportives
c'est du moins ce qu'elle démontre une
fois l'an au cours de la partie qui
réunit les femmes de ménage londonienne
cette partie se déroule
traditionnellement hors de toute
présence masculine
[Musique]
mais comme on dit en grande bretagne
honni soit qui mal y pense
[Musique]
bordeaux pau nîmes et arles monsieur
khrouchtchev a commencé sa sixième
journée française à marseille 5e ville
étape de son tour de france
le marseille corps a retenu le président
du conseil soviétique la vision d'un
grand port d'abord où le promener durant
trois quarts d'heure un dragueur de la
marine nationale mais aussi sans doute
l'image attendrissante des petits élèves
de la maternelle de l'achat chef de 212
millions de soviétiques mais je croule
chauffe est aussi grand père
grand père il est redevenu un instant
devant le train électrique offert pour
ses petits enfants à la gare de triage
de gevrey chambertin
ce qui ne l'a pas empêché de
s'intéresser aussi aux 50 locomotives
grandeur nature acheté par l'urss
[Musique]
envelopper la dira-t-il en descendeur de
l'une d'elles jeu l'emportent tout de
suite
[Musique]
le président christophe prenait ensuite
contact avec la population de dijon le
chanoine kir était excusé
la 7e journée en france du président
soviétique devait débuter par un
pèlerinage sur les champs de bataille de
la première guerre mondiale
à verdun monsieur krotov est resté lui
est
[Musique]
de la tranchée des baïonnettes à
l'ossuaire de douaumont où sont enfermés
les restes de trois cent mille soldats
français le président et est pensif et
recueillie
[Musique]
la champagne après un bref contact à
reims avec la boutique réservée à
monsieur khrouchtchev le moment le plus
pétillant de son voyage il devait en
effet à 35 mètres sous terre
parcourir quelques uns des 200
kilomètres de câbles ou vieillissants 50
millions de bouteilles de ce champagne
dont on a pu dire qu'il était une des
productions les plus représentatives de
l'esprit français
[Musique]
huitième ville étape lille
tandis que le train le conduisent est
ensuite en normandie petite détente en
gare de serre que le temps de souffrir
un peu
et c'était rouen
à rouen le président soviétique devait
admirer la cathédrale
p il dînait au palais des consuls
[Musique]
après quoi on lui offrait un vieux roi
cadeau sommes doute moins encombrant que
celui qui lui fut fait le lendemain aux
usines de flins
le tour de france était terminée au
château de rambouillet monsieur coup de
chauffe et le président de gaulle après
deux jours d'entretiens ont constaté que
des contacts personnels permettent de
renforcer la confiance entre chefs
d'état et que toutes les questions
internationales doit être résolu une à
une
non par la force mais par des moyens
pacifiques et c'est avec une émotion non
feinte que monsieur khrouchtchev a pris
congé du président de la république et
de la france
[Musique]
encore un drame dû à la rupture d'un
barrage le barrage d'auros dans le
nord-est du brésil n'a pas résisté à
l'action des pluies torrentielles et à
la cadence de 3000 mètres cubes par
seconde
les eaux se sont répandus dans la vallée
du roi garibay qu'elles ont transformé
en un lac de 400 km
[Musique]
bien que l'inondation était progressive
le premier bilan faisait état de plus de
1000 mah 100000 rivera sont sans abri
[Musique]
venu inaugurer la deuxième foire
exposition de colomb béchar ce sera vers
le court ministre d'état pour le sahara
a été l'objet de sincère manifestation
de sympathie
[Musique]
près d'adrar hatimi des fêtes avait été
organisée en son honneur et ont témoigné
de l'attachement de ces territoires à la
france à paris le ministre de la culture
monsieur andré malraux inaugurant avec
l'ambassadeur de l'inde l'exposition qui
groupe de magnifiques trésors de l'art
indien a souligné que toutes ces statues
appartiennent au divin et au légendaire
depuis trop longtemps cette sculpture ne
parlaient à l'occident que le langage de
l'exotisme
il est temps a dit monsieur malraux de
découvrir ce qui unit cds à la musique
et à la danse née avec elle
[Musique]
un mois et demi après l'explosion de la
première bombe atomique française
les techniciens se sont à nouveau
retrouvés autour du général ailleret
dans son pc de reggane il devait
assister à une nouvelle expérience
nucléaire
il s'agissait cette fois de l'explosion
au sol d'un engin plus léger
première étape vers la construction
d'armes atomiques tactique
6h15 ce 1er avril
et c'est le deuxième champignon atomique
de rega
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui en chef d'état que le
général de gaulle à retrouver londres où
l'attendait la reine elizabeth le duc
d'edimbourg la princesse margaret
le premier ministre le maréchal
alexander et les plus hautes
personnalités du royaume
c'est aujourd'hui un cortège de carros
et de cavaliers à panache qui a conduit
le président de gaulle au milieu des
acclamations d'une foule généralement
réservées jusqu'à buckingham palace où
il est l'hôte de la pop
[Applaudissements]
c'est ainsi que le général de gaulle à
retrouver londres 20 ans ap
la recette il ya 20 ans ou presque qu'il
débarqua dans ces mêmes décors un jour
de défaite inconnu sans pouvoir exilé
solitaire
[Applaudissements]
l'un de ses premiers gestes devait être
son salut à la statue du maréchal foch
en présence des vétérans des deux
guerres minutes d'émotion pour ceux qui
gardent dans leur souvenir
les images dia pas tant
[Musique]
car au pied de cette même statut de 40 à
chaque 14 juillet le chef de la france
combattante est venu déposer une
couronne fait silencieuse et passionnés
de ce groupe d'exilés qui se refusait à
désespérer de la victoire plus de deux
ans il devait continuer sa lutte dans
cet immeuble de carlton gardens dont il
fut le siège de la france libre et dans
le jardin duquel il s'arrêter chaque
matin devant la statue demeurée intacte
sous les bombardements du blitz
tout était à refaire une arme et une
marine qui resta dans le combat
vie l'homme de 18 juin au milieu des
marins qui armait une flotte réduite à
quelques corvette participer même à une
patrouille de vedettes françaises qui
faisait la police dans la manche
[Musique]
le ciel ne devait pas rester vide
d'avions français envient le général sur
les aéroports et conforter la poignée de
pilotes français dans les escadrilles
reformé participèrent à la bataille de
long l'armée française hier battu
détruites
annie les été recréé un an après le 18
juin
ces unités encore bien réduite des
filets à windsor devant la famille
royale devant une grande fillette qui
portait le nom d'elizabeth
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elizabeth 2 est aujourd'hui reine
d'angleterre
et c'est elle qui aujourd'hui du balcon
de buckingham montre au général de
gaulle président de la république
française à la fois une foule
enthousiaste et un ciel fleuri des
toiles aux couleurs jumelle de la france
et de l'angleterre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]